CGT LCS co-major Kakao is right around
the corner and it's bound to be filled
with incredible moments and highlights
so in anticipation of the upcoming major
we're counting down the top 10 csgo
clutches of all times
coming in at number 10 is fallens
incredible 1v4 clutch against Nabi at
IEM katowice 2016 black and swollen
gonna be capitalizing there as well as I
said you've won the round at that point
why are you giving your over way but
still fallen battling on there is going
to be a 301 situation
17 points of health in a dream this
would be the eighth watch from full and
I'm believing you're a bit of a believer
would you suggest that you don't want to
stop believing that one you can't their
own okay
tax up 100 I started to believe as well
Henry could he's gonna take you stop
blowing my mind this is going to be
absolute madness around until we will
forget because they go Zeus saving the
day for Navi but could you stop me back
you got away with it this is out of
around no way slowly come all around
something I thought through that time
but no Sluman not I told you you've just
got to believe sometimes Alex our ninth
spot goes to piss for this amazing one
before armorless clutch again thank you
paid off for the getting second outfit
again it hit the last man standing here
jumping PPT Cardiff it must be done
if we can get I killed at the former's
walk a nice opposition here
Oh grabbing the eighth spot is virtus
pros neo with an absolutely
mind-boggling 1v5 clutch against Team
Dignitas at Dreamhack open Bucharest
2016 we with this thing now near the
last one left you know one on four
Dignitas retaining it is not over yet
they want to fight and they want to
continue to battle neo very nearly like
the second will through the wall and now
with the smoke you can get the bomb
planted the problem is thing that sounds
have a lot of grenades fill up their
disposal kevlar nak they have to smokes
less than that's a really big company oh
because he has a Molotov and I bet he
would love to use the device time but
they've already smoke down the form
there's another head stop coming through
he'd have to go over the edge cuts into
winning the semi-final ta looking for
another spray Neos gonna get a go from
onyx yeah
kidiot backs it up hey drops right into
the grand final number seven goes to ni
pees get right for this last second
clutch against TSM yeah right Last Man
Standing device that draw speed he's
close it's gonna go down if that have
been the old C said it would have no
issue at all get right trying to walk
and 1v2 running up here with p250 out
jumping and shooting it's one more kill
looking for he's got any money down time
is up oh my god
you're already gonna be kidding me kill
him one second left coming in six is
reign was one of the cleanest one b5
clutches of all time
ruthless taking down three players now
it's just rain left alive he's going to
find a quick kill on to happy but it's
got geo schema so content with what up
rag they're coming in from rain you can
be pushing into the bottom slope the pop
is on his back he's got the smoke
recover we can make the approach to the
bombs mate you close have some climbers
why try to get the frag onto the
flanking play the game sense from this
man is unreal there's still two more
players to find though Grady's gonna get
another one
fpk goes down he's created a 101 he's
got so much time to use as well he's
going to make his way back back towards
the middle position that's right it's
tricking his opponent right now apex oh
oh my goodness gracious me rain is an
absolute monster the fifth spot goes to
hito for making us believe in
the North American dream at MLG Columbus
2016 now again as we've seen so many
times before astounded eager but against
four is it really possible we do have a
few players quite tagged up here from
luminosity so hiko definitely not going
down without a fight
oh wow that's the first box right here
go get the bottle there's still two
players left they got no help on them 13
and 3 eco creeping around the site now
there's still time it's all my goodness
our fourth spot goes too simple for this
major defining 1b to Klutch against
fnatic just doubles much in the same
plane sense it will just jump from there
for you serious what is that you guys
beat us improve and thought about is it
so SPO this is a major James dipper is
an assassin this guy is absolutely
unbelievable he's the x-factor for Team
Liquid there is no question it looked
like it was completely a shut book then
it found a way to open the book back off
its employed I don't know man if he
comes in with that open house go
decently pristine as we have one bite on
his mouth that he had one button there
was a zoom grabbing the third spot is
Niko
with one of the nastiest eagle aces of
all time well bounces by is going to be
torn away from them very very quickly by
time oh my god oh my god I don't believe
it
shox and that's justify one more the
money isn't going to touch him and what
on earth has just happened this deagle
is on fire shock you're gonna walk into
it well Niko is on fire five he recovers
the AEK as well number two on the list
is snacks with an insane Big Apple
clutch against Navi at ESL one New York
Academy and to just snacks does find one
on not leave them out of this the Big
Apple and snacks is hungry he's got one
kill already on the USP low HP is well
on Guardian and flame he's trying to
beat them out try to get media
one-on-ones and he dances back and forth
between the boss want it so much that
ball Oh
Guardian bye-bye and it's on the
claiming he captain Blamey go
what if God gave me that unbelievable
[Applause]
I've never seen anything like it what
the hell was that second special classes
I've ever seen and the entirety of
chesco grand final diverse back for this
or fourth the hell patreon even believe
it thinner eggs are on their forehead
our number one spot goes to ego but this
tech 9/8 plush against popular responses
on the seat inside a well once again
just being eco is about to pull up yeah
well we've got three from behind quad
can he find a fourth he gets support
he's odd for the a three cat just happen
I feel like I'm trapped I'm trapped
inside of ammonium right now in a human
reaction even was I need I need a
tactical timeout for the casting death
those were our picks for the top 10 csgo
questions of all time now it was really
difficult to put together the list
because there were so many great choices
but if you feel like we missed something
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button